Here's the thing. We love to act
like all these good cops
just gonna all step up
and do the right thing together.
Please, most people
don't do the right thing
for the right reason.
They do the right thing
for the right price.
I promise you if you started
giving cops $100,000 to snitch
on other cops
they would be arresting
each other at roll call.
You wouldn't even make it
out of the police station
in the morning.
"Put your hands up, Sanchez."
Something's going on,
don't know how to explain it.
Things are just different
around the department.
That's not mine,
that's not mine.
Y'all planted that shit.
Possession with intent.
Come on, I've got a family, man.
Cops are just going missing.
Do the honors.
Hey, what are you doing, man?
He's one of us.
Yeah, that's what you get
for planting evidence.
They just disappearing. But why?
You keep snitching on
dirty cops,
I'll keep paying you.
I know this much: whoever doing
all this snitching,
can't be happy with himself.
I found your drug money.
No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
- Bunny...
- What is it?
It's not drug money.
Just let me-
You brought drug money
into my house?
I been snitching, okay?
I snitch on dirty cops.
I snitched on Taylor, Jenkins,
Cavanity. I snitched on Jimmy
that work in the parking deck.
They pay me good money to do it.
They pay you this much
to snitch?
I wasn't gonna tell you 'cause
I was afraid of losing you.
Are y'all hiring?
You know what you're
getting yourself into?
Cops who go against the force
to do the right thing,
aren't rewarded
by their department.
They're punished.
No promotions.
Assigned to the worst
neighborhoods.
And when your life is on the
line, you're dead today.
Officer needs assistance.
I'm in a alley off Third.
Help me, dangit!
No back up,
snitches on their own.
Oh, he one of the good ones.
Come on, we out.
I tell you this much: if I find
out who snitch,
I'm gonna kill his ass.
I'm with you on that, brother.
Babe, I bought
two new black stallions.
What's all this about?
She undercover
at the horse track.
Cool. Alright, then,
see y'all later.
That was close.
I'll catch you at the stable.
Okay, baby. I'll see you. Shit.
Boy about to get paid!